Welcome to CS256 mobile web development. We're here
to teach you to apply your web development skills
to this, and to this because as you're probably
aware the mobile web is kind of a big
deal. Most statistics project that mobile web usage will
soon over take desktop web usage, so you might
ask whats the difference between developing for the desktop
web and developing for the mobile web. Well mobile
web development is really just normal web development
with some additional key considerations and a few additional
API's. We're going to assume that you're familiar with
the building block HTML, CSS and javascript. The mobile
web is also built on these technologies, although
we are going to cover some specific advanced features that
apply to the mobile space. Of course, there are
a lot of additional considerations for developing for mobile.
Things like smaller screen sizes and limited network bandwidth
and computing power. Well you might think these constraints are
a bad thing. In fact, developing mobile first forces you
to focus on the key points of your user experience.